[Music]
we have a smartphone here because you
think using these a lot in your spare
time you just make up characters or you
use well I don't make I don't know if
this is what snapchat is meant for I
know people Chronicle their every move
but I personally love the faces on
snapchat and they're an opportunity to
like create a character and I have a
slew of them now have you tried it I I
had other people come up 80 really
people come up to me with their
smartphones and and and do stuff and so
I'm constantly being dragged into it but
I don't ever know what's happening and
then I start crying yep you start oh no
I'm just confused and one of those guys
just confused by the view you want it do
you want to do one sure I'll do
something yeah okay oh well like for
example I mean oh my god oh my god
there's so many cap I just love
[Applause]
that's fantastic how do I live in this
world for me
you pick one for me because again I
don't know I don't know let's do one
where like something comes out of your
mouth okay or goes in okay open your
mouth
[Applause]
oh my god this is what I'm gonna look
like in two years Andy do you want to
jump in there okay let's try one for
Andy Andy do you want to be it is
excited I can see why their way by our
gross national product is just
plummeting nobody's doing any work
anymore you go into a factory who's
manufacturing the medicine in this
country no but alright we're too busy
look at our fun snapchats fun alright
let's get the word out let's get the
word out get some money from snapchat
you